beauty of the light yeah that's all guys
this is great I got my own little TV
yeah I got Adams doing a fantastic job
so far it's been really good right now
that's right I do want to emphasize the
game is oh thank you a little bit about
what you guys want to show us so I think
I mean the big thing is again you know I
think that part of the spider the
spider-man fantasy is to swing around
New York City and you know to have you
know not only just a great story but
have a bunch of different activities in
that world and we wanted to you know
give people who attend e3 an opportunity
to experience that so you know obviously
we it's a big narrative driven
experience but the same time a part of
that superhero fantasy that spider-man
experiences living within New York City
and seeing that so you know Adam is one
of he's one of our combat pro players it
cuz he's a combat designer and again
he's just showing off some really
awesome stuff that and you get better if
the game obviously you know we wanted to
have a pick up a play field at the same
time have the level of mastery and to
really show off the improvisation that
we've really been talking about a lot
since that we announced the game I'm
digging this like stick in dudes two
walls into the floor stuff that looks
really I think the thing that's been
really fun in these last you know I
would say last six months it's we got
back from the holiday break was every
week I feel like I'll take the game home
or I'll be playing one night and then
I'll come and say wow guys I didn't know
he could do that so I think is there's a
lot of that there's a sandbox nature to
it as well
so I mean obviously you can you know we
have you know we're gonna teach
mechanics but we want you to experiment
with you know his acrobatics his webs
his gadgets his suit powers so combining
all that stuff really allows for a lot
of different gameplay a lot of you know
tribes very expressive character when
want players to express that whether
it's in traversal or in combat it's
gorgeous
he's animation sorry these animations
are just blowing my mind your studio has
kind of done right now intro
and for you know just a fluid motion I
mean did you guys take a lot of lessons
from your previous games and really like
hone in on those when you're talking I
think animations definitely one of the
hallmarks of our of our company you know
from you know from Spyro to Ratchet to
sunset overdrive yeah I mean you know I
remember when the sunset overdrive
reviews came out one person actually
wrote it would be great to see and Samba
can make a spider-man game and I was
like and I waved your phone around host
exactly we took that kind of mentality
and we just injected our kind of our
personality but also you know what do
people want desire from a spider-man
experience so you know it was really
great as I remember
play around the end of the year in the
last year so nor an article about the
top things they want to see him
spider-man and they said they want to
feel like this omnia game so I think
that's the thing we've been really
layering on in this last year is to have
that it feels like an insomniac game as
much as it doesn't spider-man and I love
this traversal I mean just the fluidity
of just moving over great distances very
quickly it looks like a lot of fun just
moving around and that's when you know
you've got a great game okay so you know
how kind of said like experimenting but
like sometimes you know I mean game
development world you know well you know
we're in meetings a lot and then
somebody seems like take a break and
what I used to find myself doing was
just swing around New York City it was
almost like therapeutic it's just kind
of like when I play other games I just
walking or running or or even taking a
car - it feels so more natural now just
to swing around swing around like
spider-man
so it's it's definitely one of those
things that has that again just like
combat that pick and play feel but want
players to have a level of mastery they
play so Adams shirt off I think he
showed off the trip wire or space gadget
you can either attach to a piece of
geometry and enemies walk by they'll get
like grabbed and sucked back but you can
also attach it to you and an enemy and
if one enemy walked by they kind of slam
into each other that is amazing this is
so cool what's this focus meter about so
the focus meters basically it's there's
kind of a risk or horror as you built
focus you can use it to heal since
having a religious issue
okay thank you the team works really
really hard on it really really hard
idea it's the focus is kind of a way of
you you can risk reward like I said you
can either heal yourself or you can kind
of if you get built to fill up the bar a
certain way you can actually pull off a
finishing move so you know what as you
play the game and I say well do I want
to maybe heal myself real quick or do I
want to wait for that really extravagant
move to kind of take the guy out
instantly got it right a question for
you is obviously Spidey has as with his
experience being under the mask for so
many years now eight years or eight
years thank you you got to be precise or
I'm like no that was like decided that
the web were definitely attached to the
buildings the decided it's not good but
but you know back to the combat I mean
Spidey's experience he has access to a
lot of different techniques and
technologies how do you balance out his
experience with the fact that you don't
want to overwhelm a player with options
right you want to make it approachable
you know I really that comes down to our
combat team our traversal team like
really going okay you know kind of handy
that stuff out over the course of the
game you know finding the right spots
where you kinda okay we're gonna teach
you how to punch and cut a kick and how
to punch bags up in the air and use your
webs but then we lay layer on things
like gadgets and then the suits and the
suit powers and it just it's kind of
giving over times we just you know one
thing with some like III know we want
you to feel great right but there's a
lot to learn really quickly so we just
you know normal course development we
kind of find those spots in the game
where it makes most sense to teach those
mechanics and then as the game goes on
we want you to master those because the
games well gonna get harder yeah
absolutely said what do you think I
gotta say this game is beautiful
absolutely gorgeous this is I mean this
is just I mean it was looking
spectacular to begin with but this is on
a totally different level and I never
see that so much I can see that polish
that's the thing and that's what comes
out and that final few months of
development yeah I mean I mean if you
got I mean you guys watch the press
conference race or all those games those
first party games and they they all have
a level of polish in to be in a press
conference with the likes of and Naughty
Dog of sucker punch
push introductions uh just we are very
honored to be and we know there's a
certain level how much that people
expect from a PlayStation game that's
your first party game so we want to be
considered right up there well and not
to mention also from the Marvel you know
Marvel expect to be have that perfect
experience of course man just ask real
quickly you know as we're starting to
wind down here from a from a personal
perspective I mean what's it like for
you and for the team to be able to kind
of look up at the big screen and see
your game after after all that time work
I'm known as a crier so it takes a lot
for me not to get choked up like right
now they're playing the theme song to
the game in the background as we're
sitting here and I I mean this is an
amazing industry and to be part of it is
one thing but to work on something you
truly love it's something that when you
were a little kid thinking oh my god
could ever work on a spider-man game let
alone be in video games is it's just
absolutely surreal I use that word a lot
when I described working on this game
and to work with a group like Sony and
work with Marvel and that feeling is so
felt by so many people insomniac so we
couldn't be prouder and the support
we've got not only from Sony and Marvel
but also the fans
it just looks incredible I mean there's
no other word for it and your
flabbergast your I really am it's it's
time I mean just look at that how can
you not be blown away by that
but we do have a limited amount of time
here Brian you're an industry veteran
that you've been in the industry a long
time I know this is a lifelong dream for
you working on this game and I want to
thank you and insomniac for making it
thank you for having us
spider-man was so awesome that it broke
my mic and I have to use this
[Applause]
yeah I just wanted to stand out a little
bit but you know Syd actually I think a
little late or a little earlier we were
able to maybe get some footage of some
of the investor experiential stuff
that's going on with spider-man I mean
there really is something incredible
going on here at this PlayStation e3
showcase I mean it's it's on a scale and
a scope that we have just never seen
before and so we have people here
they're playing the game we have a lot
of hands-on sessions for folks that are
here for the showcase and just it the
game looks great but I just love the way
this whole oh I know that I know her but
I mean it's just it's a great great
event here and it's just I wish we could
get everybody in here to try this out
and to just see what has been sort of
constructed with spider-man and with
actually another game we're about to
talk about yeah we're about we're about
to talk about this yeah we sneakily
snuck on a few amazing people onto our
program as a helicopter goes by to mark
this I mean